je trouve que c'est presque encore plus
cynique si vous roulez de faire la
politique de l'émotion parce que dans le
fond pour faire bien pour faire plaisir
à vos opinions qui réclament de l'action
qui épie parce que derrière on vous dit
des enfants de photos des enfants vont
mourir
donc on vous fait ou vous la fais à
l'estomac donc on veut dire en gros vous
êtes un peu coincé vous devez intervenir
et après ses volets celle après moi le
déluge
c'est regarder ce qui s'est passé en
libye alors encore une fois là je pense
qu'il faut pas que l'occident soit roux
outrecuidant et prétendent que tout
vient lui je ne sais pas ce qu'il serait
advenu signé du régime de saddam hussein
ni du régime de kadhafi qui n'avait pas
la légitimité - semble-t-il tellement
énorme
si on n'était pas intervenus mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que à chaque fois qu'on
fait ce genre de chose qu'on va avec nos
grands pieds nos bons sentiments si vous
voulez qu'ils sont très louable on ne
peut pas faire de ça ça se termine mal
on ne sait pas quoi faire après parce
qu'on ne va pas reconstruire les états
nous si vous voulez le problème c d et
ce sont des étapes à légitime et
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on fait après on
est englué regarder les américains il
voulait partir
je suis d'accord